[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a namibia país
africano que fue escenario del primer
genocidio del siglo 20 es un capítulo
poco conocido en la historia la masacre
de poblaciones y naciones hereditarias
por parte de las tropas alemanas entre
1904 y 1908 miles de personas murieron
cuando las fuerzas coloniales de
alemania lo primero las manifestaciones
de los herero y los nada los dos
principales pueblos del país aquellos
que quedaron vivos fueron llevados al
desierto donde muchos murieron de hambre
no fue sino hasta el pasado mes de mayo
que alemania reconoció su
responsabilidad por este genocidio la
situación se complica por el hecho de
que muchos descendientes de colonos
alemanes todavía viven en el país al
igual que los descendientes de aquellos
que nacieron para las violaciones
perpetradas por los soldados alemanes a
mujeres heredero reconciliar a todos los
habitantes sea cual sea su origen es un
desafío que hoy se vuelve algo
fundamental
sí
[Música]
pero no
el cuerpo del jefe rue coro salió de la
capital window y la noche anterior a su
entierro para realizar un viaje de más
de 400 kilómetros hacia el norte joven o
viejo rico o pobre a lo largo del camino
su gente los saludó como para desearle
un buen viaje al más allá en la
tradición pura de los géneros el cuerpo
era devuelto al pueblo de sus
antepasados o el coche fúnebre era
escoltado por jinetes
si un buen líder porque nos trabajo el
dinero de los alemanes
ah
el jefe de coro luchó por el
reconocimiento del exterminio de su
pueblo en la guerra contra los alemanes
en 1904 fue adorado
[Música]
se hicieron siete disparos en su honor
la viuda del fallecido y su hermano
menor querían enviar un mensaje
la lucha continúa
no es el final fue el final de mi
hermano mayor pero no de nuestra lucha
contra el genocidio
porque la llevamos en la sangre
y la caravana siguió su camino 300
kilómetros al sur dirección o caja ancha
donde están enterrados todos los héroes
de la lucha de una genia
[Música]
el jefe rue coro murió de kobe al igual
que los otros dos negociadores del
histórico acuerdo con el gobierno alemán
[Música]
de salir
los grandes soldados no mueren
simplemente se desvanecen en el mundo
del silencio el silencio que es la
esencia misma de nuestra existencia
[Música]
dos meses después el pueblo se reunió de
nuevo en un cancha esta vez bajo los
auspicios de la fundación del genocidio
enero que mantiene la memoria de
aquellos años ya sea en texto o en
fotografías la eliminación de la
población civil de la colonia alemana
conocida como áfrica del sudoeste está
bien documentada desde los campos de
concentración hasta las ejecuciones
sumarias el poder colonial no puede
negar las atrocidades pearl y se ha
disculpado públicamente con windows el
pasado mes de mayo acordó dar más de mil
millones de dólares a namibia
realmente no me importan sus disculpas y
reclamamos lo que nos han quitado
romanos y lo que nos quitaron fueron las
vacas nuestros medios de producción
nuestra tierra la tierra que nos
quitaron los alemanes no se la llevaron
en una bolsa para alemany que todavía
está aquí sus hijos están sentados en
esas mil millones no son suficientes y
matemáticos como este profesor calculan
al céntimo lo que su comunidad perdió
entre 1904 y 1908
mi bisabuela nos contaba cómo los
animales daban a la gente y luego los
puedes imaginar el trauma psicológico
que tenemos
todos los herero y nama necesitan
terapia así que también cuantificamos
eso el psicólogo cobra 80 dólares por la
consulta
y asumen que éramos 320 mil heridos
se necesitarán al menos 8 millones de
dólares solo para la terapia para estas
comunidades que viven entre el presente
y el pasado hay que tener en cuenta el
trauma intergeneracional
también existen estas creencias en la
reencarnación que las personas que vemos
son en realidad la reencarnación de
personas que tuvieron hace años que no
completaron la mención que debían hacer
en la tierra por lo que se les pidió que
volvieran para completar esa misión
siempre reflejamos aquello por lo que
luchaban a veces los antepasados somos
parte de ellos y algunos de nosotros son
probablemente antepasados que han
regresado para completar su misión
esta profesora cuya abuela está
enterrada en okasan ya visita
regularmente a la familia que nunca ha
salido de su tierra natal su tío abuelo
vive muy mal dice que confía en las
autoridades tradicionales para negociar
con los alemanes aquí todo el mundo
piensa que en mil millones es poco y que
hay partes de la historia que han sido
completamente olvidadas la cuestión de
los niños por ejemplo nacidos en la
violación de mujeres ereros como ghost
lee un mestizo que se presenta como
descendiente de un soldado alemán
en 1904 mi abuela también estuvo en
caída
durante la guerra entre los alemanes y
los herederos ligeros y todas las tardes
cuando hoy vamos a recoger leña para el
fuego se ponía a llorar al pasar por un
lugar determinado
a veces lloraba toda la tarde mientras
íbamos a por leña
siempre le pregunté por qué siempre yo
horas cuando vienes aquí
solo por las violaciones hay que hacer
todo un juicio en los tribunales y luego
la manutención todos los padres alemanes
que han dejado hijos aquí deben
brindarles un sustento somos la tercera
generación de niños aquí
si las palabras son tan belicosas es
porque los tiempos son duros en estas
regiones desérticas
[Música]
en namibia la mayoría de la población
vive con menos de dos dólares al día y
las tribus que fueron diezmadas por el
genocidio son ahora las más pobres del
país muchos se preguntan qué habría
pasado si el 80% de la población entera
no no hubiera desaparecido entre 1904 y
probablemente nuestra forma de vida
habría sido radicalmente distinta porque
con lo que nos quitaron no podíamos
progresar
ha tenido un impacto en nuestro nivel de
desarrollo
por eso la mayoría de los heros y nada
más también
que los alemanes tienen que enderezar
esto para que lleguemos a hacer lo que
deberíamos haber sido si no nos hubieran
robado
4 y thomas
más de 205 mil vacas fueron confiscadas
durante la guerra si se suma la tasa de
natalidad y una sequía cada 10 años
entre otros factores el ganado o valdría
hoy miles de millones de dólares según
el profesor los herederos también
calculan que han perdido 50 millones de
hectáreas de tierra berlín decidió
financiar proyectos de desarrollo
durante 30 años en las 7 regiones
afectadas por la guerra de 1904 para
compensar los retrasos en el desarrollo
en la capital de namibia el embajador
alemán habla de indemnización no de
reparación no se trata de dar dinero
directamente a los demandantes como en
el genocidio judío después de la segunda
guerra mundial
recibieron reparaciones pero solo los
que estuvieron en los campos de
concentración
mientras que en este caso estamos
hablando de segunda tercera e incluso
cuarta generación que se consideran como
digamos las comunidades afectadas
los descendientes de las víctimas se
manifestaron frente al parlamento de
namibia para tratar de impedir la
ratificación del acuerdo entre las
autoridades namibias y alemanas los
herederos por supuesto estaban presentes
pero también los lamas que habían venido
a expresar su desconfianza ante tanto
dinero entregado al gobierno de namibia
[Música]
el asunto se convirtió rápidamente en
algo político
[Aplausos]
y nuestra historia no puede ser vendida
para este régimen por el que no votamos
este régimen es corrupto no representa
nuestros intereses
se llevan los diamantes del sur
pero no cuidan a la gente de allí
por eso la gente del sur está hoy aquí
para demostrarles que somos seres
humanos no perros
dormimos en la arena ni siquiera tenemos
un baño
cuando queremos hacer nuestras
necesidades
simplemente cruzamos la carretera
los camiones que pasan por la carretera
tocan el claxon
pitan porque las mujeres están haciendo
sus necesidades en el monte porque no
tenemos nada decente para nuestras
mujeres allí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace un siglo los herederos y los damas
habitaban dos tercios del país en el sur
rico en diamantes la mitad de la
población de nada más fue diezmada por
las fuerzas coloniales los restos de los
antiguos campos de concentración son un
recuerdo del triste pasado y los
afectados por el genocidio son ahora una
minoría pero sus reivindicaciones
dividen a todo el país
sua común es una pequeña ciudad costera
en la que se han instalado muchos
descendientes de colonos alemanes pero
también hay muchos novios de origen ama
antón es un antiguo diputado cuya
familia ha vivido en namibia durante
tres generaciones se crió en el país de
los nada más hoy asistió al lanzamiento
de la semana del patrimonio cultural de
namibia en el museo de sueco
[Aplausos]
asegúrese de celebrar su cultura y
enseñar a sus hijos quienes son
respetando al mismo tiempo otras
culturas como somos tan diferentes en
namibia tendemos a chocar pero debemos
ser la generación que cambie las cosas
convertir el conflicto en celebración
respetar que el otro haga las cosas de
forma diferente porque esta diferencia
es nuestra razón de ser
[Aplausos]
el abuelo de antón llegó tres semanas
después del inicio del levantamiento de
los herero en los primeros barcos de
refuerzo de las tropas coloniales tenía
19 años este monumento en el que podría
haber aparecido su nombre se erigió como
homenaje a estos jóvenes soldados
alemanes pero como explica antón ahí
surgió una controversia
en las manchas rojas en las piedras
la gente ha tirado pintura porque no le
gusta
y si algunas personas se sienten
realmente ofendidas por este tipo de
monumentos
2 y el sentimiento compartido
en otras comunidades culturales nuestras
relaciones
entonces creo que deberíamos pensar en
quitar ese monumento lengua
awards
antón intentó averiguar quién era su
abuelo preguntó en los archivos de
múnich friburgo y berlín pero le dijeron
que todos los documentos sobre las
tropas coloniales alemanas habían sido
quemados al final de la segunda guerra
mundial lo único que sabe es que su
abuelo se casó con una chica que trajo
de alemania esta es la única foto que
tiene desde 1904 tras la guerra el
soldado se convirtió en agricultor
por supuesto
web
era consciente de que podría haber
interpretado un papel que no me hubiera
gustado
pero para mí todo es pasado es familia
religioso de post
sin embargo en cuenta a través de mi
vida las interacciones que tuve con
otras comunidades culturales de mi país
de que no era así para todos
por eso estas reparaciones tienen que
marcar la diferencia para las personas
con las que se convive
para que finalmente puedan cerrar este
capítulo de tu y alevín where the west
show de taken explic close detecta
en namibia el tiempo se detuvo los
descendientes de los caballos de los
soldados alemanes forman ahora manadas
salvajes todo en el presente recuerda
del pasado colonial para pasar la página
habrá que seguir discutiendo porque a
pesar de todos los esfuerzos de todos
los conocidos del país nadie ha
conseguido todavía ponerse de acuerdo en
una lectura común de la historia
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a namibia recuerde que
si quiere ver este y otros contenidos al
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom